ce que nous contestons et ce qui nous
révolte des mains dans ce qui est
présenté aujourd'hui par le gouvernement
d'edouard philippe et et la logique des
manuels macron c'est qu'au fond la re
distribution se fait au profit des plus
riches parce que il y a en gros 5
milliards d'euros n'est nouveau le
budget de purisme budget de risque oui
on entend depuis mais il faut être
concret pourquoi parce qu'il ya d'un
côté 5 milliards d'euros bah non c'est
pas facile c'est passé
non c'est pas facile notamment pour ceux
qui vont subir ce qui ce qui risque
d'être décidée non 5 milliards d'euros
pour les plus riches par le biais de la
réforme de la sf et d'autres niches
fiscales qui vont être favorisée et de
l'autre côté des prestations sociales
pour le grand nombre qui vont elles être
miné et donc 5 euros en moins d'appels
on le sait la csg pour les pour les
retraités qui va augmenter donc c'est ce
sont des mesures très concrètes qui
concerne aussi la santé puisque vous
savez que le tarif hospitalier le
forfait hospitalier va augmenter lui
aussi de deux euros donc je vais pas
faire toute la liste mais si vous voulez
au final c'est à robin des bois à
l'envers qui est aujourd'hui à la tête
de l'état est ce que vous pensez que le
groupe majoritaire à un public en marge
on va voter ce budget en tout cas va
être là et voter les mesures comme un
seul homme ou alors qu'il peut y avoir
un début de fronde y compris au sein de
la majorité
qu'est ce que vous sentez à je ressens
que dans la majorité il ya des moments
où ça coince c'est évident et là on le
voit sur les yachts sur la partie la
plus je dirais impopulaire des mesures
c'est incompréhensible que d'exclure les
yachts les jets de la saison moment même
on nous explique qu'il faut contraindre
les budgets publics
c'est honteux vous dites c'est honteux
donc un certain nombre de depuis député
qui peut être juste se sont promenés
dans leur circonscription rencontre est
née des habitants qui leur ont dit
écoutez c'est indécent peut-être qu'il
va y avoir une petite à la marge
quelques amendements favorables mais ça
ne change pas la logique est pour
l'instant en effet au gouvernement
le gouvernement a une majorité à
l'assemblée nationale pour voter ce but
et mais je ne crois pas qu'il ait une
majorité social une majorité d'idées
dans le pays pour mener une telle
politique est une politique de deux
voilà que deux classes justement parce
que le mot